we're joined now by dr anthony fauci
president biden's chief medical advisor
dr fauci good morning thanks for being
with us
uh good morning anthony and happy
birthday thank you very much
uh dr faji as we just heard omar report
the delta variant now accounts for
nearly half of all
covid cases across 10 states
why is this the most dangerous variant
we've seen so far
well it spreads much more efficiently
than the virus that we've been used to
over the last
several months to a year and also data
from the uk
indicate that it also is more dangerous
than that it makes you
more seriously ill so the combination
of a virus that spreads more rapidly and
has the potential to make you more
seriously ill
is a threat we have to worry about
that's the concern on
unvaccinated people the good news is
that the vaccine protects against it and
that's really another
very powerful reason why we want people
to get vaccinated because this is a
threat
it is now well over 90 percent
of the isolates in the uk are this delta
variant which is causing them a
considerable problem
so you're expecting this to be the
dominant strain in a matter of weeks
it will be the dominant strain among
those areas those regions of the country
where the vaccination rate is lower than
we would like
for those areas where you have a high
vaccination rate
you're not going to see that again
another powerful reason why we need to
get vaccinated
dr faunchi why do you think the
messaging from you and this white house
administration wasn't able to
get us to that 70 percent threshold
you know i think we better really be
careful because we've done extremely
well
so we're gonna probably by the fourth of
july be i don't know 67 68
that's really good the 70
aspirational goal by the 4th of july
to get individuals with one single dose
to get 70 percent of at least
one dose was an aspirational goal but it
was never the end game i mean we want to
go right through july 4th into the
summer
continuing to get people vaccinated so
the fact that we
not quite at the 70 number by the 4th of
july
i wouldn't make that much about that
because we still have done
extremely well we have over 50 percent
of the adult population completely
vaccinated
and about 65 percent of the adult
population
having received at least one dose and
we're doing very well with the elderly
more than 85 percent of the elderly
have been vaccinated with at least one
dose so we've done well so we don't want
to fixate that we're a couple of
percentage
points lower than we would have liked to
have been on the 4th of july
but we're going to be really close to
that dr faucia
i'm curious do you we know whether yet
whether kids 12 and under
are more susceptible to this delta
variant
you know i don't think you can say
they're more susceptible but when you do
have a virus
that is much better at a transmitter
children are clearly going to get more
likely infected
than they would have with the original
for example the alpha
variant so it isn't that they are more
susceptible but this
virus is a more transmissible virus
therefore
children will more likely get infected
with this
than they would with the alpha variant
all right dr anthony fatchi thanks so
much for being with us this morning we
do appreciate it
thank you good to be with you